[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have our first official look at the
Morbius character ahead of the trailer
that they're going to be dropping next
week so we'll break it down if you're
new to the channel we're also doing a
movie ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be subscriber and leave all
your predictions for the Morbius movie
if it wasn't clear this is going to be a
spinoff of the venom movie yes it is
related to what's going on with their
spider-man plans inside the venom verse
we know a little bit about how that's
going to work I'll explain that after I
talk about what's going on with the
actual Morbius movie cannot wait to see
Jay jonah Jameson showing up in a
post-credits scene shitposting about
vampires it's gonna be fun people are
saying that this teaser leaked but I
think that Sony actually dropped this on
purpose in advance of the trailer just
to get people hyped up if we're the most
part I think people are happy with the
CG special effects because it does look
pretty comic book accurate but this
doesn't give you a really good idea for
what the actual movie is going to feel
like it just gives you an idea for what
he's going to look like it's a picture
of him right after he's gotten done
feeding on someone and it's an homage to
this comic book panel like an
over-the-shoulder shot he's looking to
see if someone caught him feeding oh my
god what's going on here because he
can't control his hunger if you're a big
fan of the Wesley Snipes blade franchise
way back in the day there were
originally plans to do the Morbius
character in one of those sequels they
even have a deleted scene from the first
blade movie they were gonna introduce
him during the sequel before Guillermo
del Toro came on and did his version of
Blade 2 the footage is kind of janky but
this is that deleted scene
I never thought I'd be so happy to see
the Sun Rise
[Music]
I need to get back to the lab I'm gonna
cure him it's over
you keep with you
I've never felt better
besides as long as there's a war going
on I still have a job to do
the new bathroom club
[Music]
I'm a big fan of Guillermo del Toro but
it would have been cool to see that
version of Morbius if that had panned
out if you have no idea who the Morbius
character is or you never read the
classic spider-man comics he is a
spider-man character he debuted during
amazing spider-man in the early 70s it
was basically Marvel wanting to do their
version of a dracula character because
the 70s was a really big time for the
dracula character in pop culture so
Marvel just wanted to get in on that
Morbius was their attempt at an original
character based on Dracula though but
the funny thing about this is because
Sony doesn't have the rights to do the
Dracula character Marvel Studios does
because of the way the comic books
worked out and where the Dracula
character debuted in Marvel Comics
there's a rumor right now the Dracula is
actually going to show up during the
werewolf by night moon night series that
they're doing and during the Blade movie
that they're gonna be doing with Maher
shal ally during Marvel phase 5 maybe as
part of their grand sharing arrangement
with the spider-man character Marvel
will also loan out the Dracula character
for their Sony venom verse to do Morbius
stuff with and sequels if the first
movie is successful but the whole idea
of Sony doing Morbius is then testing
the waters with other spin-off movies
they of course want to create their own
version of the MCU because it's been so
successful for Disney and Marvel and as
part of the way the rights with the
spider-man character work they have
access to over 900 different characters
Morbius is called the living vampire but
he only has vampire like qualities he
didn't get his abilities through the
vampire bite like most do he started out
as a Nobel prize-winning biological
scientist he had this rare condition
that was eating his cells alive so he
developed a treatment using vampire bats
blood in electroshock therapy when he
eventually tried it on himself that
caused an accident that gave him his
vampire like qualities turning him into
quote-unquote a living vampire the way
that Sony and the venom verse is setting
him up though is to be an antihero just
like the venom character yes I
definitely think that they're setting
them all up for a crossover in maximum
carnage so Morbius will wind up teaming
up with venom you know because of the
Sony Marvel sharing deal Tom Hollands
spider-man will also crossover with them
eventually - you may have also seen the
rumors about what they're doing with Jay
jonah Jameson so Sony controls the Jay
Jay character they loaned him out to the
MCU for spider-man far from home for
that great post-credit scene I thought
it was a great way to reintroduce
the character and also sort of connected
to the Tobey Maguire spider-man era
because they kind of skipped over Jay
jonah Jameson during Andrew Garfield's
run so if you haven't seen it the rumor
is now that Sony's gonna use him as an
early point of crossover to weave
together all their venom burst movies in
the Tom Hollands spider-man MCU movies
so he showed up at the end of that movie
so he exists in the MCU now but the
rumor now is is that he's going to cameo
during the Morbius movie and during
venom two in the same type of role doing
the same thing just total [ __ ] posting
about the main character of each of
those different movies so you can
imagine him going on and on about
vampires existing in the real world you
thought they were fake no they're
totally real we have live footage we're
going to air it now is a really easy
slam-dunk so I high-five whoever had the
idea to use Jay jonah Jameson to connect
all these dots together if you didn't
see it recently to Sony also created a
special separate real website that you
can visit for the Daily Bugle dotnet
that was the one that they referenced
during spider-man far from home post
credit scene Daily Bugle Nets Jay jonah
Jameson has a live report if you go to
the website it's basically him going on
and on about all these crazy theories
about why Avengers endgame and the snap
happened why everyone came back about
the elementals that Mysterio created how
there are weird creatures running around
so Sony is now using as a viral
marketing place for all their spider-man
related stuff and that'll probably wind
up including venom stuff when we get to
venom two coming out later this year in
Morbius later this summer really good
example of how they've used that for
viral marketing is that after spider-man
far from home came out the movie was
done they didn't shoot any new footage
for the movie itself but they shot a
bunch of new promos with JK Simmons
doing his J jonah Jameson thing is if
you were in his studio and he was still
reporting on spider-man stuff
take jonah Jameson here spider-man a
psychopath wielding powers he has no
right to possess trying to pass himself
off as a hero well let me tell you
something kid you're no hero Mysterio
that's a hero you are a criminal a
miscreant a masked Marauder a menace
thanks for watching don't forget to Like
and subscribe so that's not something
that they did for the spider-man far
from home movie that's just something
that they're doing with this new Daily
Bugle dotnet web site I know there are a
lot of questions about how spider-man is
going to figure into all this in later
this summer marble is gonna start
shooting spider-man 3 so are they going
to have some sort of post credits tag in
that that will imply how he will
eventually crossover with the venom
characters when Kevin Feige made the
announcement about the new sharing deal
he referenced the multiverse in
spider-man jumping between cinematic
universes in addition to different
planets at the multiverse right now Sony
is developing a Madame web movie my
early guesses is that they'll used
Madame web is a way to explain how he
crosses universes because otherwise
you'd have to use someone like dr.
strange or Scarlet Witch or someone
capable of that level of technology or
magic and it sounds like based on the
sharing arrangement between Marvel and
Sony Sony has the rights to reference
any spider-man related stuff from the
MCU but not the Avengers not the quantum
realm or anything like that so I don't
think that the quantum realm is going to
be the way that they used to get
spider-man between Sony's venom bursts
in the MCU the Morbius movie was shot to
make it look like it was happening in
New York City in venom - looks like it's
shooting scenes set in and around New
York City
spider-man is local to New York City
even though technically he's in the MCU
right now you can kind of see that
they're bringing these characters into
each other's orbits eventually they'll
start crossing over probably in advance
of a big maximum carnage team-up movie
where they all team up against the
carnage character so most important
characters in this movie are Jared
Leto's Michael Morbius character who
becomes Morbius the living vampire his
love interest Martine Bancroft who
herself becomes a vampire eventually in
the locust crown aka the hunger
character played by Matt Smith you heard
it right Matt Smith is gonna be the
villain of the Morbius movie he's not
quite the exact same thing as Morbius in
the comics but he has the same blood
disease that eventually causes him to
have to feed on other living things in
order to survive so he's also very
vampire like we don't have to wait that
long before they're gonna drop the
actual trailer that's happening Monday
of course I'll do a Easter Egg video for
it and we'll find out what the movie is
actually going to feel like I think we
all kind of wondered what venom was
going to be before we actually saw a
footage but at least for right now it
seems like they've nailed the look down
so everybody just post your reactions
in the comments and let me know what do
you want them to do with the Morbius
character inside this larger connected
spider-man in Venom universe I know that
a lot of people asking if this is going
to prevent Jared Leto from ever playing
the Joker again there is a version of
the Jared Leto Joker that's going to be
used during the birds of prey movie but
Jared Leto himself was actually filming
the Morbius movie when they were
shooting birds of prey so we need Joker
stuff that you see happening during
birds of prey next month because the
movie is coming out really soon is gonna
be a body double or hinges off screen
it's not Jared Leto actually being in
the movie himself let me know if there's
any bonus videos that you want me to do
our big request for spider-man videos
while you wait for everything click here
for that brand new Doctor Strange 2
announcement that Marvel just made and
click here for my new Deadpool 3 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight